number one I don't think she's suffering
from the attention I think she's because
people people are absolutely fascinated
by everything that's going on with her
and they're following her every move I
think she's suffering because i do think
she I believe that she's ill and we've
talked to a lot of different doctors at
Star about her and ask them what they
think and actually my best my best guess
after speaking to number of
psychiatrists and psychologists is that
she's got a histrionic personality which
is a personality that actually craves
being the center of attention and can't
live without it and I think she's and
the doctors that we spoke and you also
think that she is bipolar that she's
both things which you can be so I think
she's suffering from those things
however I don't and I think but I don't
think that she her career is being
destroyed by the paparazzi her career if
anything is being destroyed by the fact
that she's not able to focus on it
because of her illness that she's not
able to go out and promote herself and
promote her album I mean her new her new
album her CD blackout was really good
it's terrific if she if she could have
gone out and done a tour if she could
have done you know proper marketing and
PR it would have sold a lot more copies
but I think there's a there's still an
enormous amount of interest and sympathy
for her most of her fans and the people
who just observe her would love her to
get better and to be the old Brittany
they want her to succeed that I want her
to fail they go there people are
invested in caring about her so it's
really pretty interesting so I don't
really I don't think that it's the media
attention
which is the problem